patience critically ill with the
coronavirus are being helped by these
artificial lung machines in China's
southern Guangdong province more than
6000 nationwide are in serious condition
but the government says numbers of new
cases are falling the World Health
Organization says other countries must
learn from China the experience that
China has had needs to be shared and
this is the this is an excellent example
of that that direct interaction is what
we want is what we want to see more and
more happen more than 100 people from
Hong Kong have arrived home on the first
government chartered flight from the
city of Wuhan the epicenter of the
outbreak more flights are planned for
this week in South Korea more than 5600
cases have been confirmed people in the
hardest-hit city of daegu say there's a
shortage of masks and they're having to
queue for hours to buy what's available
passes how much you put into dollars of
way all the people especially here in
Daigle are at great risk
I've been waiting line since 5:30 in the
morning and haven't even received a cue
ticket the South Korean government has
announced a nine point eight billion
dollar stimulus package to protect the
economy in India a sudden jump in cases
on Wednesday fueled fears that an
outbreak could grip the world's
second-largest nation almost 30 cases
were confirmed after a group of Italian
tourists tested positive for the virus
the state of Rajasthan the children find
it difficult to leave their houses if
someone has to go somewhere like travel
on a bus or go to a public place they
feel scared cases have topped 1,000 in
Japan but Olympic organizers say
preparation for the Summer Games due to
start in Tokyo in July is so far going
ahead the Chinese government says the
steady drop in new cases is proof that
severe lockdown restrictions have worked
for reports that some killer patients
are testing positive for the corona
virus after being discharged from
hospital
our raising new concerns Chinese
authorities say these patients are not
likely to be infectious but of ask those
who have recovered to undergo a further
period of quarantine before we entering
the community Katrina you al-jazeera
Beijing